hi everyone my name is Michelle I am a
recruiter turned health coach so 24
years in recruitment and more recently
have become a certified health coach to
basically help keep recruiters happy and
healthy we're having some technical
difficulties that okay you're good
you're good run that I think all morning
everybody I'm Rhonda damper Ozio yet
started in the industry back in 97 have
done all manner of jobs in recruitment
and from the resource and element right
through to running my own business and
other people's businesses I now work
with recruitment businesses on quality
of thinking and growth mindset I'm
transformation Directorate even able and
I'm the founder of mental health in
recruitment thinking of Adaline the
mother of dragons label as well because
I've got so many different hi I'm NIH I
to spent a long time in agreement Eliza
almost 23 years again contract permanent
enhance my own business business as well
and I now teach mindfulness in a
no-nonsense no fluff no guru kinda way
so most recruiters nice eats out and
speak about that okay love that thank
you I'm a great to have you here last
but not least Katie may [ __ ] thank you
well as a chef just said I'm Katie may
cook I am the founder of get your [ __ ]
together literally and figuratively I
actually spent around ten years in and
out of corporate sales and a lot of that
was in recruitment where I personally
burnt out twice so now what I do is I
would work with companies in particular
recruitment companies talking about the
impact that stress and anxiety has on
the body as well as the mind so I help
people manage the stress of it because
as we all know recruitment a bit of a
roller coaster so awesome well yeah okay
thank you for joining us and as I said
we can hear you loud and clear
so all good so look what I wanted to
kick this off with is and just a bit of
a big question that
question that was submitted by Murray
but I think it's important I think
particularly with you guys with what you
do I think it you always hear and see
people would talk about how we shouldn't
be talking about mental health just for
a week right and nothing that's fair but
I think at the same time I think it's
great that people go above and beyond to
try and talk about it more or do things
this week so that I don't think that's a
bad thing but a question that on the
country run the first and is submitted
by Murray Prendergast which was
basically how can we make sure the
mental health and is being discussed as
being spoken about in a cultural
recruitment business more than just this
week how do you make it how can we start
making sure that it's not just the this
week that we think about it speak about
it and and sort of do things with it so
let's just start there great question
Murray and I know that we'll probably
have some opposing views on this but for
me it has to start with intent before we
can drive the action on an ongoing basis
there has to be commitment from the
business from the leadership and you
know the way in which I would recommend
is identifying champions so I think the
recruitment business needs to set out
their intent to obviously get on board
with this and identify those champions
throughout but including and especially
at the top okay
Michele absolutely completely agree with
that the senior people have got to be
leading that if they are sort of sending
emails late at night then that's gonna
sort of encourage the more junior people
to have to respond to them so completely
agrees with that but also it doesn't
have to be major things it can be small
little changes the same as you kind of
commit to having your sprints every day
go okay put in some small things that
actually about encouraging Mental Health
so whether that's you do your one to
one's walking instead of sitting in an
office or instead of constantly bringing
in kind of sweets and Pro nuts and beers
with her nothing never do that but maybe
not every day maybe get the fruit basket
in because we are what we eat so I think
that sometimes people think it's got to
be massive changes and actually small
ones can be answer as
I love that and then offense well yeah
it's kind of a mix of the two really
it's the intention from the leadership
team to say like this is something we
are implementing we genuinely care about
and then it's making sure that those
small changes that you implement that
follow-through like you know we know how
many recruiters were sousveillance right
and I'm so one company who said
basically they're not like they're crazy
love the area where people go and sit
for lunch and you only like to work yes
and like why saying that as the rule
then it becomes the norm and toadies
everyone to have that breaks there are
definitely with those and again with
Rhonda having ambassadors so men for
house first aiders people in the company
who are openly talking about it and
you're allowed to you know approach and
have these you know sometimes difficult
conversations to say hey I'm doing
really well and this is what I've been
doing so can we share that sharing
what's working for people I love that
okay what have you seen businesses zero
up every supposed to just add to that
yeah so I think one of the biggest
things that are I okay we can't hear you
bit a bit delayed news is actually under
that you've broken that you've broken up
inch doning that it has to come from the
top down okay it's definitely delayed
but it's breaking up which is annoying
because obviously we just usually speak
and fun and do occasionally give that
another go and I'll move on yeah
yeah does it can you hear me now we can
but it's just yes you know what everyone
okay all right cool
appreciate Katie pop yeah that you can
pop it in the the presenter chat at the
top it's just a bit harder because I
can't see your face so I'm trying to
live done if you go and speak again or
whatever but and so look what as we saw
plan together and how how we're gonna
sort of go through this today one as you
guys are watching this feel free to ask
your questions as we're talking but
we've sort of identified together there
there's like we want to talk about the
common challenges that you guys are
hearing and speaking to recruit is about
we wanted to stop there because for me
obviously a lot of recruiters can think
and assume that the challenges they're
facing if that's mentally if that's
professionally whatever it may be just
unique to them and having obviously
speaking to those recruiters every day
with what I do I know that's definitely
the case I wanted to really start and
sort of make sure that people are aware
of the common challenges that people are
facing so we solve identified a couple
of the the ones that you guys hear a lot
of so look Emma let me let me come to
you first
I think it's a big one and sort of one
of the things that we identified
together and what you as really keen to
speak about was some of the sort of
mental challenges that you're hearing or
people face being on furlough so I guess
why don't you sort of kick off sort of
talk a bit about that and then we can
chip in or add anything to it as well as
we go through yep perfect yes so it was
interesting was winning all first
happened the nervousness and the
uncertainty come up like am I going to
be furloughed what does Ferno actually
mean like you know do I want to be
furloughed do I don't no one really
understood it very well so that break
its own sort of challenges as it moves
through it and more people have been
furloughed the the challenges that are
coming up are interesting it's like some
people it's the guilt the guilt of
having to work and my colleagues who are
having to work doing it all and the
guilt
yeah we're not used to
doing anything we're used to being
productive and creating on the phone oh
my god I'm sitting in the sunshine
having a beer at 3 o'clock and there's
noise that is initially it does start to
you know that the guilders often kick in
why wasn't I wanted to chosen ones to
know this business going you know I was
doing really well I was like all my
targets
you know the management like me the
client so why have they kept that person
working and not made does that mean I'm
not and then there's the that future
insurgency like okay so though what does
that mean if the business doesn't do
well what's going to happen to my client
base yes sort of stuff is coming up for
people yeah and sort of Michelle what
like one of you because I think from
what I've been hearing light is like
peat businesses well better businesses
have tried to really make sure they have
touch points and communications with
their staff to the furloughed and and
definitely part that is the sort of
check-ins if that's run mental
well-being or whatever so I'm sure some
of you guys have been involved with some
people that on furlough whatever but
whatever you sort of picked up on I
think that there's sort of the
assumption that if you're on furlough
that's great and as it we were saying
cuz some people that is brilliant but
actually for some people potentially if
they're self isolating on their own
they've lost their sense of purpose what
my minute do all day once I've kind of
painted the walls and done the garden
what else is left to do so when I'm
working with the recruiters and the
business leaders it's really important
to not forget those people and go well
not how to work for the business so
therefore I don't have to speak to them
until they walk back through the door so
one thing that I encourage is regular
check-ins with them they asked her apart
this getting them involved in whatever
activities you got going on the quizzes
or the scavenger hunts or whatever that
might be so that they still feel part of
it and some companies are actually doing
sort of undoes specific talked for the
people who are on furlough not just for
them so we can talk about the things
that they're really feeling so it's two
sides because you've got the pressure on
the people who are still working to keep
the business going and get the furlough
people back in as quickly as possible
and then you've got the furlough people
who it sounds like it's a nice thing and
it's great that the government is making
sure people can get paid but
fundamentally you've just ripped out
kind of their whole routine and morning
is due for now I think also it's I mean
my my girlfriend got got put on furlough
pretty much from the first week it was
available and I mean it's a long time
like if we've like that's a long time
like obviously I've sort of seen the
journey that she's been on it's been a
rollercoaster like hundreds and it's
been really bad days some really good
days but it's definitely up and down and
I think early on it can be like yes we
apes and I'm never gonna get this
opportunity get to do this again I've
signed up for this course from the learn
the new language I'm gonna do this do
that and then the guilt can trick him
with that as well conning Emma when you
end up actually looking back in your day
it's like [ __ ] off what the beer our two
p.m. this day today yeah yeah yeah as
well keep him as well it's like the
denon s like yeah the workers there say
friendships that they even have you know
colleague friendships have kind of felt
slightly frayed because you know she
said if you'll refer Larry person
phoning up you know it happens for
talking to your non-throw friend going
to God like God I'm just like so bored
and they're going holy [ __ ] I've got
targets here not getting anywhere I've
been on the phone all day
it adds pressure to those relationships
really
all right so obviously yes so definitely
plenty of Chinese here and being on
furlough
I think Rhonda let me come to you on the
next one and then Kay I'll get your
input nurse I haven't forgotten about it
trust me so so runde obviously one of
the things that we identified and that
you was really keen to speak about and I
think this sort of ties in quite nice of
this because it was all about balance of
handling the pressure and being
productive because I think that's even
true being on furlough as well you know
I mean so I guess what what have you
been hearing and speaking of recruiters
about that have been sort of combating
that handling pressure and also being
productive if we're all in this very
different situation with a different set
of circumstances that are impacting us
right now and there is the pressure to
perform because there is a level of
anxiety around what will happen will I
get furloughed just tying that back to
that yeah there is a we've never worked
in this way before for the majority of
recruitment businesses so you know I
need to do my very best but how do I do
that because nobody's talking nobody
wants to speak to me nobody wants to
give me jobs and for a huge proportion
of recruiters there is a parental
responsibility whereby they have to look
after the kids they're trying to
home-school the kids and if they're
young how do you do that you know how do
you balance the pressure of your family
life and obligations along with the
pressure of trying to perform in the
workplace and and do the best that you
can do and you know I've heard a few of
us have touched upon this in different
ways
Michelle reference zoom fatigue I call
it the remote working acuity whereby
when we're doing so many of these video
calls
we are straining because it's difficult
to build those levels of relationship
build rapport you know you're trying to
read how people are responding so
there's there's almost an anxiety of am
I being taken in the right way do people
agree with me because the nonverbal
communication is so we take it for
granted we absolutely do I message
someone's yesterday about let me go old
school and give you a call on the mobile
and they really appreciate it I'm doing
exactly that because they're talking
about the pressure in the conversations
that I'm having it's
do we need to be on all of the time you
know I've got me on my video so you know
there is a first of all people need to
be kind to themselves and you know take
a little bit of a break in their
thinking from a multitude of reasons and
when you work from home typically you're
more productive because you don't have
the same amount of distraction that you
would get in a conventional office space
so you have to really measure that level
of productivity we've taken the right
amount of breaks and Michelle mentioned
Sprint's earlier on Emma's talked about
that that anxiety of the disparity
between those on furlough those not on
furlough you know we got to be kind to
ourselves and we've got to really just
make sure that yeah yes it's okay and
that really for me you know ties into
what we're going to talk about around
the practical tools as well advice but
it's a common theme but what I would say
in comparison to that I'm talking to
business owners and business leaders
that are very aware of it and I did some
work for a company last week whereby
they wanted their people to know that
they understood the pressures they were
under and they didn't apply even more
pressure onto them which I just thought
was fantastic
hmm now I think that's I think we spoke
about this before run go see especially
recruiters listen now that they will
have high standards of themselves they
they will sort of want to make the most
out of what's going on and there's also
that internal pressure and and sort of
and then on top of that Tim does my
company and need me to do this I'm
worried about not doing this for them
and that added pressure as well and
Katie what have you been hearing on this
then in terms of that sort of balance of
handling the pressure and being
productive what conversations have you
been having yeah so hopefully you can
hear me I've got my a stick so I guess a
lot of the conversations I am having is
really similar how do we manage the
people on furlough how do we manage the
people that are off furlough and I think
the element is I've been speaking to
recruiters and companies and leaders of
the companies talking a lot about how do
we not burnout right now and I think
that there is this pressure to be able
to perform so the people that are still
working they're trying to perform the
best that they can
they've got kids at home
we've got partners at home and then also
it's a lot more stressful because people
aren't hiring people aren't placing jobs
so there's this element of I know I
can't be doing too much I want to be
productive but I don't know what to be
productive on and they think that
there's this you know there's a guilt of
not doing enough work but then also the
guilt of
what can I do so a lot of stuff that was
that I've been talking about is hi
actually let's focus on a little bit
about what can we do right now to help
the mental health of our of the team how
can we actually help the people on
furlough I've actually been working with
companies on doing mental health
check-ins with staff on furlough going
actually like hey let's actually bring
them in let's actually do a whole group
thing because they're allowed to do the
training they're allowed to come today
yeah sessions so I've been you know I've
been doing a bit of that and checking in
with their mental health and also
talking to the people on what you can
actually be doing and actually focusing
on small goals not the big goal and not
focusing on what we can't control
focusing on what we can control today
and actually at the end of they're going
you know being able to put your head on
the pillow going to know what I've done
enough and and that's hey I'm one of the
biggest things that I'm talking to
people about is hey we're in a really
weird time in the world we need to make
sure that we're physically and mentally
and emotionally fit right now as well as
for when we come back so that's what I
love that and yeah heard you loud and
clear
Katie absolutely fine and but that that
segues quite nicely into Michelle what
you wanted to talk about and things that
you've been talking about Katie talking
there about putting your head on the
pillow and feel like feeling like you've
had a good day well you've been speaks a
lot of people been putting the head on
the pillow and happy now to get to sleep
so worried about that because that I
mean my biggest challenge had definitely
been switching off and that definitely
couples into put my head on the pillow
and then I'm thinking I've got all these
[ __ ] my dear swelling around my head
and I can't get sleep and then I'll need
to write things down so like yeah just
talk a bit back because I don't want
people to feel like it's just them the
conflict right now or finding it either
to sleep yeah absolutely it's probably
one of the biggest things that when I've
been doing sort of my talks to
recruitment businesses or doing the
one-to-one coaching with people and
they're sort of coming up and asking me
questions sleep is coming up
time again firstly can't get to see
secondly waking up in that danger zone
between 2:00 and 4:00 and thirdly which
is a new one but it's happening a lot
it's really bad dreams people having
kind of not this kind of like normal
dreams were actually quite vivid dreams
so what I'm doing actually explaining to
them the science of what happens during
your sleep what happens at different
points of your sleep so that at least
they understand why is that suddenly
their sleep is so different making them
realize that they are not on their own
is something that people are talking
about all of the time and fundamentally
if we don't get a good night's sleep we
all know that we wake up feeling rotten
the next day the idea of picking up the
phone and making some BD calls or so
doing some reference cause or whatever
it might be is just like I am too tired
so for me it's kind of almost like let's
not worry so much about whilst we're
awake let's focus on that night Tom Moss
we're asleep get that right and then
everything else just becomes that bit
easier yeah okay interesting like I'm
not in tune with my daughter not
sleeping so she really and she's do
don't you know she's developing the
inability to get to sleep as well as she
could and we're doing all the things you
know working and you know what happens
with her and I'm sure it happens with as
well is that the pressure to get that
sweet because we know how important it
is she sang to me like I won't go to
concentrate you know and then that adds
to the pressure so it's it's the same
way in this is what you doing like [ __ ]
me to get to sleep I've gotta be cool
tomorrow as soon as you get caught in
that loop you're in trouble in the end
yes really I mean I got the tools and
you guys I'm sure have as well that just
had to get out of that loop and do an 8
and yourself good sleep these are the
things like the she'll probably know
more right the house side of things yeah
yeah there's a lot
so look really excited now to just sort
of segue into sort of practical tools
and advice but just quickly on what
people might be thinking our I'd love to
know Emma what you do before you get to
sleep or what's your sort of before bed
routines let's just talk about because I
think there might be some more practical
things or useful thing about that what
why don't we just like what's been one
of the best things that you've done this
sort of helped you or helped you with
your sleep routine or get getting to
sleep maybe over the past couple of
weeks or just this you know I have to
get I have to get out of the house I
have been away from my computer have to
shut it all going I have to write down
everything ready to do so it's all my
head but the main thing is going is
writing things down and I need to do so
it's out with my head and going for a
walk like Anna good walking like five
minutes round the block I'm talking like
a good being outside lungfuls of fresh
air really having that energy or
whatever it is that you like to do
energy that's been attracted by you
sitting at your desk all day yeah I
write writing down sort of what your
intention enough for the next day
definitely helps me yeah wonder what
what sort of helps you I would say I do
I do two things I don't necessarily
write down my intentions for the next
day but I make peace with the day that
I've had I kind of close the day off
reconcile I can't I can't can't do
anything now to impact what has been I
now new dish not down ready to back it
up for the brain to do what it does and
then that do you like write you write
gee I don't know do you write something
down or is that this you doing that
mentally sane right okay Rhonda I've
done them for Mike and today yes I
actually you know for those of you that
are familiar with the whole Titanic
thinking I shut my compartments I
literally both in your illustration in
my mind if I'm closing the compartments
and I move into one side and it was
great
there's a great technique with that with
really stuff that you shouldn't be
bothered with
I actually put it in a steel container
and wrap a chain around it and throw it
in see that's for nothing and then the
other one which I'm really big on I I
tried to do my best to not look at my
phone but I do run him bin I'm not
infallible I listen to Michelle's videos
on LinkedIn and I think God I'm so you
know I've got doing more of this stuff
I'm no I'm good with the mind not
necessarily or that I I make a point of
not going on LinkedIn or any bit because
exactly what you said here zoom if I do
that if I jump onto my LinkedIn feed and
I see one tiny thing that sparks I'm
then business planning in my hand right
yeah and I can't I can't shut down so
those are the two things that I do know
I really like that's all I'm making
peace of your day I think that sauce and
that's something I definitely more of
and Michelle what what that you were
sort of your non-negotiables and saman
she starts the day before so um what
thing in the morning completely impacts
what your sleep is going to be like for
the night so first thing in the morning
I get up and I go outside great if it's
a walk or a run or a bike ride but even
if it's just physically taking your
morning coffee outside what happen the
sunlight hits your retinas and I'm not
suggesting you stare at the Sun
employment get sunlight into your eyes
because it starts the hormone process
and it basically switches off your
melatonin which is your sleep hormone it
turns on your serotonin which is your
day hormone and then basically it starts
the whole hormone process which
completely impacts you at night so those
people who are going to bed later
getting up later
well willing straight out bed to their
machine staying at the Machine all day
and then wondering why they're not
sleeping at night just putting in that
break first thing in the morning where
you get daylight in your eyes will
actually mean that your body process
will start to work so my first one is
daylight in the morning and my second
one is we are ultimately adult babies
and if I gave you a child and said
you're responsible for putting that
child to bed tonight you would have some
even if I don't have children
but I know that you probably think them
about half six you probably put past
them about seven put them in bed for
half seven read them a story ideally
they're in bed for eight ideally but we
have processes that we work with
children to get them sleeping perfectly
and then as adults we basically rip up
the rulebook okay I'm gonna ignore all
of that and then it's have a good
night's sleep so kind of like rewinding
and going what would you do if your
child wasn't sleeping properly
how would you enable it you wouldn't put
an iPad in front of their face just
before bedtime you'd make sure that
their bed was really comfy that it was
dark that it was quiet and gives them
sort of it's like going into a hotel
room isn't it where you go I know I'm
going to sleep really well tonight
they've got those thick curtains that
keep all the lights out so it's just
looking at sleep hygiene and sort of
making sure you're doing everything you
can
awesome lots not hke any what was your
yeah I think Michelle and I had the
exact same human because I actually
talked about in exactly the same way I
actually don't say it's not what you do
in the evening it's what you tell you
start your date
so I'm actually an X insomniac to be
completely honest with you so I've
actually suffered from insomnia most of
my teenage and adult years so one of the
biggest things was actually having my
morning routine down pat so no phone
checking my phone in the morning making
sure I go outside to get some fresh air
setting up my day in a calm way without
having that stress an impact of looking
at an email or something you know
straight up in the morning so actually
allowing my body to pretty much set up
for the day my evening routine again
would be switching off from everything
I'm one of those people that you know
fly exactly like Rhonda and sham if I
see something I'm one of those people
that look like I'm latched on to Anna
now that I've got like another couple of
things that I want to do the other night
I couldn't sleep properly and I created
a whole webinar just probably don't do
that again
may I actually try and not talk to
people after about 8:30 9:00 o'clock at
night because I actually finds that
stimulates me the other thing that I
will say for people that are in that
moment of not being able to sleep and
having that sort of vicious cycle I'm
not sleeping I'm gonna feel pretty
crappy tomorrow is actually just be okay
it's just like if I don't sleep I'm
gonna be okay and it's not the end of
the world I will be able to just reset
tomorrow I'm gonna stick to my structure
and I'm gonna do it tomorrow and be okay
with that I use it because otherwise you
fight it if you if you keep fighting it
you're not gonna be able to get back to
sleep so except that you might just have
had a bad night's sleep but that's
that's okay and you can also choose
these are the other thing you can
actually choose how you want to feel in
the morning if you want to be pissed off
you can be pissed up if you go do you
know what may make most of the day even
though I haven't slept I'm gonna do what
I can
today it actually shifts the mindset
from everything's really bad I'm having
gonna have a bad day I'm gonna feel
shitty - it doesn't really matter I'm
gonna I'm gonna do the best I can I'm
gonna be as productive as I can and just
and sort of having that mindset peace
there is what I know my husband said
something really good on that good on it
and like when you you know if you lying
in bed you're not asleep you're still
letting your body rest do you know what
I mean so it's kind of quite nice just
to accept that I lose my body's rest my
body's being held I'm in this and even
if you're not like fast asleep having
that amazing sleep you want
I'm still getting my body a chance to
relax and that's okay right now that's
that's enough I can just chill here and
listen to the meditation or sleep music
or something and it's okay man I'm not
actually see which goes with what k2 the
saying about like it's okay like you
know to not always have the best night's
sleep ever like you still you know
survive you will you know function ya
shown that and then ya got some so many
good questions coming in that I'm gonna
get to you but just just really keen to
you and say going into practical ideas
and that people got saying yeah not
being on my phone or start over to
drinking water that that's a big thing
for me soon as I wake up I drink a lot
of water and that massively helps me as
well and but Emily let's come back to
you because I think the segue is quite
nicely into it and we were talking about
it which was one of the sort of real
practical things you want to talk about
Emma was basically letting yourself
being and sort of experience the the
feelings it's all the advice or things
he speaks people about so why don't you
just expand on that a bit yeah and the
reason I genuinely believe I got to that
point was I was disconnected from myself
I was so used to pushing so used to
achieving you know just going and going
and if things come up that I didn't
really want to feel or think about then
I would just you know the look is going
okay like I wouldn't let myself feel it
but why would I why would I want to let
myself you know like put it away and
what I've learned over many years in
studying this and studying myself
because it's like really interesting to
study yourself amazing is to realize
that you know these are all emotions are
valid like no matter how you're feeling
it's valid and we give them we give some
emotions so much power when really if we
just let ourselves feel that emotion
except that we're feeding that emotion
right now like I'm feeling [ __ ] I'm
feeling really sad let yourself feel sad
like how does it feel in your body what
comes up in your head cry scream and you
know it goes so much quicker
it just goes quicker if you try and
suppress it and hold it down and not
doing that it just keeps coming back up
it's like I think if I can ball in a
sling call you push the ball down you
know eventually it's going to fit them
come up and bang on the back of the head
so you might as well just netball Bop
around that's a good an overly
hmm okay feelings they're all valid even
if you're having you know you feel so
fortunate view for highs and kids are
healthy and you still feel [ __ ] that's
okay he's that kind of [ __ ] take
yourself in shape and then move on yeah
right jump jump in on that as well about
the feelings and the emotions and the
crying if you stop yourself from crying
you actually release cortisol so it's
even though you think that you're gonna
feel you're holding it back you don't
cry you don't feel even worse by doing
that exact thing you are having an
adverse effect like you mostly when you
say that making your body more stress
like yes if you just cry then it's a
better flow in terms of your chemicals
and then as Emma said you get to what I
call you gear change into choosing then
the behavior in the outwards action yeah
No thank you Emma so I want a I want an
artist and a question that Ross Taylor
sent me which i think is a great great
great question and so Michelle let me
let me come to you on this one so Ross's
question is basically what advice does
the panel have for encouraging people to
open up about how they're feeling when
they are naturally uncomfortable talking
about it how can leaders get an
authentic check on what's going on with
their employees who don't want to talk
about it that I'm sure this is something
that leaders think about and it's a
challenge so what comes up for you when
asked that question this happens quite a
lot and actually I have sort of leaders
who say I'm struggling to get people to
talk about how they're feeling can I put
them a session with you so that you can
do one thing actually that I've been
doing is on my talks at the beginning in
the chat box I get people to say where
in the country they are and one word
that to explain how they feel that day
and I say please don't put motivated
just because your bosses on here will
get overwhelmed tired sad and it's about
kind of that then gives the boss is a
chance to go oh okay actually maybe that
person needs a bit of support but I've
got a great so this is a tool that I got
from a guy that I know a guy who called
Craig brand
recruitment Business School City Tech
and we talked to me about asking people
twice so if you are someone first time
how are you let's be honest we all go
get ya know hello and actually kind of
ask the question a second time
people are firstly it gives them a bit
of time to sort of go oh actually I said
I feel fine but I don't we're talking
about our body so I feel fine and then
they're more likely to open up but I do
think that maybe you need to look at
sort of who's the person asking those
questions so company mental health or
they just kind of select me because
maybe they they have a different way
about them they're sort of whether it's
that they're sort of more approachable
or whatever it might be so it might be
that actually the business leader if you
don't feel comfortable asking those
questions who in your business would be
someone who could actually work with you
up I know my husband used to have
someone we referred to as his work wife
and you would basically like the person
that would go come on we're going to go
for a walk we're going to go and have a
track and people do very comfortable
talking to her which meant that he knew
that sort of he didn't have to kind of
not worry about it of course he worried
about it but she was looking after those
people know if it's not your natural way
that's absolutely fine see who is that
can be that person that sort of that ink
to listen to for people to know that
they're not going to be judged because
people are too scared at the moment to
say they're struggling because what if I
lose my job and also to know it's
confidential so that's the most kingpin
if someone's going to open up to you
about whatever they're feeling they need
to trust that this isn't getting
reported back and he's being kind of put
by their name for the future yeah no
great voice I Michelle and okay let me
and come to you on this to maybe add
some more but I love that how asked how
are you twice I think that's such a
practical thing you can do in it it
generally stops you in your tracks which
is sometimes something that you need do
you don't know
get out how are you twice twice how yes
great and then it's on to the carry-on
so I love that okay what anything to add
on sort of yeah what leaders can do to
try and encourage people to open up or
find that difficult what yeah a lot of
the times I think leaders now we've been
talking about you know being vulnerable
and how to encourage vulnerability in
the workplace and you know we've been
talking about it so much but I think
that you've got to recognize you've got
to see where you are currently the
culture that you currently have and how
far away are you from actually
developing that vulnerability you're not
gonna flip a switch and go oh I'll be
vulnerable now like I feel really
comfortable you've actually got to build
that trust up you've got to build the
new structures up and they sometimes
looking at a long-term plan as well as a
short-term plan is really important so
how can we build up that trust how can
we encourage people to be vulnerable and
I think in the recruitment industry I
have seen a pretty big shift and people
trying to be more vulnerable it's just
you know recruitment companies seem to
be on sort of like hey let's sprint to
marathon it's like you know it's a
marathon we've got we've got to slowly
build up there the people we've got to
be encouraging and also as leaders they
have to work on their own aren't
comfortable being comfortable with being
vulnerable and building up that that
that process for themselves the one
thing that I always get asked when I'm
sort of talking to business leaders it's
like I can see someone so it's not
coping but every time I say I can see
you're not coping they're not really
responding and it's like yeah because
you're making them feel bad they're like
oh they're like I didn't realize you
know a lot of the times people think
that no one really knows what's going on
around them but when you got to someone
it's like hey I see you're not coping
it's like holy [ __ ] am I going to lose
my job like you don't want to my job so
it's being able to understand the the
emotional cues and I love the asking how
are you twice because I have people
myself I might say how are you would say
yeah you know how really are you and I
think that I think being comfortable
knowing that you might as a lady you
might not be the best person to have
those conversations and and encouraging
that within the work in the team is
really important as well but that's a
lot would add to that yeah that's great
and Saranda obviously what you wanted to
talk about in terms of practical advice
which i think is really important is
realigning expectations
and I think that that can help a lot of
people so why don't we talk a bit about
that yeah I think this is counts for us
as individuals and us in the workplace
as well we're really hard on ourselves
let's go back to that productivity the
pressure and all the things that were
handling with handling when we realign
our expectations what we're doing is
we're saying that the goals that we're
setting ourselves to achieve are easier
in Grasse they're they're closer for us
to reach and by doing that and by
realigning them we're going to achieve
our goals ambitions whatever it is
actions much easier and faster and every
time we do that we are going to release
our little surge of dopamine one of our
happy chemicals and dopamine is what we
feel when we are anticipating a reward
so it works on a couple of different
levels because if we realign the
expectations of our self then there is
less chance that we're going to get
these what I call the negative automatic
thinking and if we do it in terms of
what we apply it to the workplace and
what we're doing we can take more breaks
we can do the mini goals we can do the
sprints and we can stop being as hard on
ourselves and it's that compassion that
we have for ourselves in these
situations which can make a massive
difference rather than beating ourselves
up rather than thinking we haven't
achieved enough we can say right this is
what I'm gonna sound to achieve today
and maybe you're going to achieve five
six seven things instead of one massive
thing and it's quite it is alien for us
in equipment to do this because we've
been brought up with the this is your
target these are your incentives this is
how we want you to be driven and
motivated but we must remember that
every single one of us has individual
drivers and motivators tapped into our
core our perception our frame of
reference and stuff like that so how I
access my happy chemicals it's going to
be so different to how you access yours
Katie accesses hers and so on and so
forth and this is where leaders miss a
little bit of the trick you know and the
whole piece for me around it we somebody
said it earlier on if we can understand
some face science behind how we think
and how we feel it's much easier for us
to not almost have this personal view
and say god I'm terrible my life's crap
I'm not good at anything we can separate
the identity in the behavior and that's
really really powerful it's like I
thought
talked about this yesterday for those of
us that have got kids when you tell a
kid you know no you're naughty that's
terrible yeah it damages them as an
individual and it's the same for
ourselves and all and how we manage when
we say to our kids that's not good
behavior yeah I didn't like that you did
that that wasn't good behavior we're not
saying that we we don't love them or
there's a problem with them we're saying
that those actions weren't right for
what we expect
so those clear expectations of ourselves
and if you are a leader those
expectations of the people around you
yeah you need to communicate you need to
be transparent and you need to be clear
and it makes a huge difference I I could
talk about that for ages a billing
manager on the last one I did of these
so they are really well because we're
talking about changing expectations
their staff are they've managed and that
was a big question for a lot of people
as to how they're measuring success or
activity of their staff and productivity
and she put it in the really obvious you
you hear the advice all the time focus
on the things you can control control
the controllables and she just tied in
there with the expectations so she said
what we've done is adapted our
expectations of our staff expectations
myself only on things we can control and
I think that that really helps is that
because if your expectations are just on
sort of things that you can't quite
control you can have an impact if you
can't control that that can even foster
even more of you being mean to yourself
and not being kind to yourself because
of that so I think that's some great so
quit a great question come from Charles
Curtis Emma let me come to you on this
one is I think this is a great question
what what things can managers look for
or tests to establish any mental health
red flags with their consultants what
comes up for you on that it's tricky I
think
and obviously if you've got very strong
relationships with your team it's
probably a little bit easier to identify
the other thing with red flags as well
is you could have really good at hiding
them like really hiding like okay I'm
not gonna go on my video I'm going to
place I'm going today something like
sharing
like the confusion that comes in I think
if they're shooting you then it could be
a fact they really really are holding to
see it and and we go into again get
through those which is to me is the
managers and the leaders showing their
ability so depressing no putting
technique with mental health and it's
like actually you know you can find
someone and say oh my god I yesterday
drives me mad it's terrible and I hated
life I hated everything how are you
doing how do you have any bad days and
that level then there gives them the
chance if you've seen those really gives
them the chance to kind of do it but
really I think it's going to be a
consistent approach you've got to be
asking this to everyone because as the
people who hide their red flags
they will not in your hide yes Stefan if
achill isn't a Michelle and if into an
ad I think the thing with it is anxiety
is kind of a secondary emotion that it's
often invisible so not only to others
where you put that mask on but it can
actually be invisible to yourself I know
I went on a three-year journey of
sickness exhaustion and I have no idea
is related to stress because I was just
used feeling that way so I think
sometimes it's kind of and what happens
when we're in that state of anxiety is
Emma was kind of talking about is that
the prefrontal cortex which is the
decision-making part of our brain
switches off we literally lose our mind
so we like I don't know who to call
I don't know how do I do a reference
call how I use LinkedIn anymore when you
start to kind of go that it's going okay
the anxiety is kicking in but I think
it's so much about the senior speaking
up so when I do the talks and like to
get this Q&A bits at the end when the
senior people start saying I'm
struggling I'm not sleeping I'm just fed
up trying to do Big D cause when no one
I I can't even get through to them
because you have said it there is no
longer the reception person that you try
and get passed by them opening up you
suddenly start to see now this is okay
for me to say actually I'm the same I'm
drinking too much I'm not sleeping well
I'm getting sort of panic attacks or
whatever it is that's going on so it's
those small changes if someone sort of
is normally really bubbly and they
become a bit quiet or if they're
normally a bit quiet and they suddenly
become a bit bubbly it's like keeping a
little check that yeah like that um okay
just conscious of time or see Michelle
what I know what you was really keen to
speak about which is obviously having
the clothes off this session is sort of
the power of breathing and why it helps
so why don't we touch them and talk
about that for a sec and then I'd love
to just go around and sort of talk about
what kindness means to you and then
we'll finish this off so yeah Michelle
why don't we talk a bit about that okay
so for me everything really starts with
the breath and this is not room ooh
hippy Amin this is science this is about
the fact that when we are stressed our
adrenalin and our cortisol levels go up
to basically get us away from Dane
when we're anxious the prefrontal cortex
switches off and what deep-breathing
does is it sends a message to your brain
to say you are no longer in danger so
therefore your stress hormones can
reduce and your brain can turn back on
so I think people completely sort of
with the challenge with any form of
breathwork is either people haven't
tried it because why would I or they've
tried it and it didn't work for them but
it's called a practice you got to find
what works for you you find the time of
day do you like to sit up or lie down do
you like someone certain voice and it's
like we talked about running a marathon
you wouldn't do it on your first one you
were trained for it
so a lot of work that I do is actually
about getting people to try it getting
them to see that feeling that just in a
couple of minutes your whole body just
starts to feel calmer because you have
changed the chemicals in your body
anyone who's ever heard about wim HOF
he's known as the nice one he's Dutch
guy look him up he basically has done
crazy feats of sort of like climbing
Everest in a pair of shorts through his
breath my husband is a breast coach and
he's working with athletes to increase
their sports performance he's working
with CEOs to get them sleeping better
he's working with people who are going
through surgery to get him recovering
better all through actually managing
their breath using the oxygen properly
so yeah for me anytime ice any talk that
I do anytime I talk to anyone is like
let's do some breathing we all think we
do it properly and yet we don't we
mainly do it wrong and it's so simple
and it's free so don't go to Holland and
Barrett and buy if it might be its own
powders like just three yeah and when
you say just just quickly Michelle when
you're talking about those things like
does that mean it has to be meditation
so I normally don't call it meditation a
bit about sort of that I mean yeah
because people might be thinking that
it's just simple as that whether there's
so many different types there's
relaxation meditation there's
visualisation
affirmation there's breath work but
ultimately it's just breathing
everything's at the end really yeah the
biggest misconception I've meditated for
a while on and off sometimes it's been
always in my day sometimes it hasn't but
the biggest misconception is that you
have to sit there and not and like empty
your force and you're not going to think
about anything which is the just
complete wrong thing it's just about
getting better see it noticing that
you've drifted off and you come back to
the breath noticing you drift off again
and come back to the breath and you're
not going to sit there and not think
about anything that just isn't gonna
happen in my but it probably isn't and I
think that sort of common thing isn't it
that people think that's what they have
to do like their and that worries people
having to sit there and just not think
about how the hell along the dinner five
minutes in a day to sit and actually
just think is that a bad thing or if
you've been meditation and you fall
asleep is that a bad deal it's whatever
you need to get out of it sometimes I
want to feel really calm sometimes I
want energy sometimes I want have a good
cry sometimes I want clarity of thought
it's like there are so many different
types
it's about finding what you need at the
time of day that you need it and
literally it is so transformational but
it's like building any habit habits are
based on success nothing to do with
repetition and when you try to meditate
and it didn't work you you feel you
failed
you don't bother building they a bit
yeah
we're definitely some breath work today
which I'm excited for so let's just go
around Kate let me start with you and
obviously with the theme this year being
kindness what what does kindness or what
does what yeah what does kindness mean
to you Katie went with that being the
theme what what does that mean to you
yeah so for me I'm probably you know I'm
my worst enemy what majority of this
time and so sometimes I'm paying
attention to the words that I'm saying
to myself and actually going I would
never speak to anyone regardless if
they'll my friend or an enemy like that
so actually having those moments and
Hankins taking a massive step back and
actually really evaluating where I am
and
really happy and kind of proud of what
I've achieved
and where I'm at and how I'm going and
just having I'm really paying attention
to my wins and not where I failed or not
what I haven't succeeded that because
realistically I've burnt out twice and
recruitment purely based on the fact of
looking at all the areas that I wasn't
doing a good job and I wasn't you know
it was trying to be better than you know
where I was but realistically actually
appreciating I'm on a journey and I've
dumped freaking awesome and actually
being really kind and and you know
mindful of the fact that hey I'm on a
journey be saying that you know this
ain't a race like you and embracing
everything that's coming along and also
having those mental checks of having
understanding like wins and actually
knowing you know what I'm doing okay I'm
doing the best I can and that's
completely fine there's nothing wrong
with that
I love that Emma what does kindest mean
to you it's getting to know yourself
like spending the time to get to know
yourself and then learning that you know
what you might label is good or bad is
on partying and just learning to kind of
live those bits Mick doesn't come
overnight again like the mud breastwork
or anything he takes practice to kind of
go oh my god I'm such a dick about that
sort of stuff and then going why am i
and exploring that and kind of sort of
getting a place of acceptance and a
place of non judgment about yourself and
saying okay that's that's what I did
then and that's okay and that that South
exploration for me is kindness to myself
understanding that you know what I'm all
about
what I need and when I need it like
what's good for me and what isn't when
I'm when I'm getting tired like you know
when I'm getting tired I'm getting
grouchy why am i carrying on like being
kinds of us I'll be saying actually
getting grouchy because you're tired so
go and sit down look at the tea study a
bit and so getting to know the sound so
that you can be kind to yourself and you
know what you actually need love that
awesome Rhonda what if harness mean to
you I'll be really quick
for me personally it means compassion
you know guys have touched on it but I
start with stop with compassion
compassion is behavior or as kindness is
an action for other people it's the
difference between empathy and sympathy
sympathy is divisive sympathy is almost
position it's a power play where you
know you could say to somebody or you I
feel sorry for you but you're not
actually feeling it so employing the
empathy where you really understand the
situation or you can imagine being in
that same situation it's just vital
Michelle so the ladies have done
brilliantly talking about self-care and
self-love which is where it starts you
got put the oxygen mask on yourself
first but also for me kindness and one
of the great things towards sort of
helping mental health so it's mental
health awareness week is actually
kindness to others it's really good
doesn't it when you do something nice
for someone else and at the moment I'm
the sort of volunteer for my street and
I go and I get shopping for vulnerable
people and oh my goodness sort of almost
acts because I'm doing something for
them but I feel great for it I know like
cycle isn't it is that sort of be kind
to yourself because if you're not kind
to yourself you can't be there for
anybody else and managers and leaders
you need to really take that on board
when you're just holding the weight of
everybody on your shoulders but also
small little things to help other people
it's also going to make you feel so
positive release all the happy hormones
which all helps with mental health I
love that do it and just quickly before
we go into the the breath work Michelle
is just a question by Megan Smith and I
think it's just a real practical one
that people like to ask so let me come
back to you Michelle and what's your
like go to book recommendation for
mental well-being or mental health
they're typically recommend my number
one this is for people who suffer but
this is also for people who live or have
friendships with people who suffer
because called reasons to stay alive
it's fine Matt Haig my husband struggles
with his mental health he talks very
openly about it and I must have made
when I met him my thought was snap out
of it come on I can't do it and then he
gave me this book to read it's not very
big book it's really nicely written it's
this guy's story of his journey through
depression and it opened my eyes and
there's a quote he says that trying to
explain depression to someone who's
never struggled is like trying to
explain earth to an alien and it
literally even now that makes me can
attract yeah it made me realize that
this is not snap out of it this is
actually people are having to deal with
this it's a constant battle and you have
good days and you have bad days so for
me that book title and author in the
chart and then this appeal yeah Rhonda
what's your go-to book recommendation
god I talk about it all the time it's
Carol Dweck's work on mindset so Carol
Dweck mindset you know she's a Stanford
psychologist who's pioneered the whole
growth mindset concept it's a great read
it's not dry it's not boring science and
there's some good business as well as
personal stuff in there and that all the
time the general like like I kind of
like reading as well if you're not
necessarily suffering from depression or
anxiety or stress but you want to just
keep you know even yourself happy wise I
quite like you okay making money and
it's just like positive positive
positive stuff it's seven
is it not necessarily mental for anyone
suffering mental health it's just giving
the milk yeah and I mean mine would be
one would be an NK I'll come to you mine
would be a power of night now Eckhart
Tolle that had a big man on me I found
it hard to read that first and then I
sort of picked up again and then and
then the other one that people should
definitely check out it would just
actually give you a lot of Education is
and Johann Hari on
called los connections that that's just
a just an amazing book where you
actually get an actual real insight into
what the [ __ ] that this whole thing is
about and actual reality in people's
stories and stuff Contras right yeah
it's awesome
it really isn't he's been on his own
journey with it as well super vulnerable
and goes through that and Kade last but
not least what's your book
recommendation for people yes so I'm
actually not sure so I would actually
say I think it's breaking the wild by
brené Brown I think that's a really good
book especially if you're looking at
vulnerability and the second book that I
actually think is really easy it's very
easy read is the chimp paradox and I'm
blanking on the guy's name but I think
it's so I actually think that's an
awesome book to read especially if
you're trying to understand emotions
anxiety stress and understanding I'll
hang on a second like you know mmm how
do I manage this that's a good one cool
well look so so I just want to put this
to everyone or see it and five past
twelve
Michelle very kindly sort of willingly
said that she's going to take us for a
bit of a five-minute breath exercise
with us talking about this bah blah blah
so we're gonna obviously four of us here
gonna sit here and probably look quite
stupid on the screen and look so thank
you so much everyone for joining and
feel free to join in with this feel free
to leave that's absolutely fine and no
offense taken but Michelle very Connie
is going to take us through a bit of a
brief exercise to finish this off it to
be a couple of minutes and then then
Willie will also I'll end this if I
don't fall asleep
[Music]
okay so we'll keep it so divided we've
overrun so I'll keep it sort of short
and sweet but this is so you can
actually just get a feeling of what it
feels like so don't close your eyes yet
but you will do in a minute I want you
to sit yourself up straight with your
feet flat on the floor if you're sat on
the floor sit
Legg age however is comfortable but kind
of ground yourself but your back up
straight over your ribs are all open
because your ribs are meant to be like
that and when we sit all day our ribs go
like that which means we can't breathe
properly I want you to relax your
shoulders and when we get going I'll
tell you what else to do with your face
but I'm just going to talk you through a
really simple technique it's called four
four eight and we're going to breathe in
for a count before we're going to hold
for a count four and we're going to
breathe out for a count of eight I'm
going to talk you through it twice and
then you're going to do two rounds at
your own pace because I might count
quicker than you breathe if possible I
want this all in and out of your nose
your nose is for breathing and smelling
your mouth is for eating and talking
if medically you can't breathe through
your nose then contact me separately we
can talk about that but if possible
please breathe through your nose I'm
going to want you to put your hands
palms up on your lap the reason for
palms up firstly there's a lot of nerve
endings in your hands but also if you
look at my shoulders when my palms are
down my chest closes in when my palms
are up my chest opens up so you're going
to sit upright you're going to put your
palm somewhere cont'd ibly in your lap
now I want you to close your eyes now
because I can't see you or when you
finish doing this I'd love if you could
put one word in the chat so just tell me
how you feel so close your eyes relax
your shoulders relax your face if you've
got any little scrunch in your face that
little kind of stress feeling just try
and relax it
I want you if possible to let your
tongue sit in the top of your mouth
that's where it's menaced it most of the
thymus doesn't so here we go
remember in and out of the nose breathe
in for four three two one
hold for four three two one breathe out
for eight seven six five four three two
one breathe in for four three two one
hold for four three
- one breathe out for eight seven six
five four three two one
now two more rounds at your own counts
okay when you're finished just put one
little word in the chat so I know that
you've finished they were sure it was
sweet there's a lot more to it but what
I just wanted to show you was that was
less than a minute so throughout the day
when you're stressed you've had a
difficult call with a client or
candidates not doing what you're hoping
they would do you can simply take one
minute out you can do it standing up you
can do it sitting down and it is just
about that deep breath as you would have
breathed out you would have felt your
body relaxed you are changing the
chemistry of your body this is not women
but for anyone that likes the feeling of
that and wants to try something else go
and follow this account on Instagram
love to learn - they do - free breath
work sessions a week on a Wednesday and
a Sunday evening it's amazing breath
work it's - fantastic music it takes you
on a journey and whether you are
struggling sleep whether you are
struggling to have clarity of thought
whatever you will come out of it feeling
better
I'm loving there we've got aware we've
got content we've got clear we've got
lifted we've got relieved you're like
come on anyone on here you sort of do
this with your teams every morning when
you do your morning chat before you
actually kind of finish it off just do a
minute of four for eight because they're
setting you up for the day anyone is
shrugging do it before you go to sleep
as well let me show that was also
sometimes it's a bit like if you don't
have the voice for a bit you've
definitely got a nice voice for that no
I just wanted to say thanks to Michelle
Rhonda Emma Katie and thank you so much
being so open honest give me some real
good advice talking about this thank you
and everyone for joining us thanks for
being vulnerable and probably feel quite
weird just sitting there and listen to
Michelle and doing this honestly well
done you and thanks for joining us hope
you got tremendous amounts of value for
it I know that these lovely lady
if you ever did want to speak to them or
have any troubles or issues or whatever
honestly reach out to them make sure you
connect with them and they're the people
that you should know so big thank you
guys I really appreciate it